if you want to discuss politics or the
show or really whatever with other David
Pakman show viewers and listeners a good
place to do it is the David Pakman show
subreddit you can find it at david
pakman.com slash read it and this
morning I was checking out some of the
recent threads and discussions that were
there I want to share a couple of them
with you and one of them asks is the
State of the Union address even a
necessary or relevant tradition anymore
I think it's pretty clearly not it's
tradition it's really what it is well
there's no there's certainly no
necessity and the relevance of it is
medium at best right I mean you just you
don't need it but it is a tradition the
Constitution does require the president
to speak to Congress from time to time
yeah doesn't have to be every year in
that format correct that's just how
we've done it traditionally that's
exactly right so I believe that the
State of the Union address is not cest
necessary and it is not relevant but
it's okay to do things because of
tradition if that's what you want to do
there might be some other value to it
and whether it's seeing Donald Trump
sort of clap for himself or whatever
right we could still say that that it
makes sense to do it also from the David
Pakman show right a discussion forum
Trump's first State of the Union ratings
dip from his 2017 speech I'm not really
reading much into the entire ratings
thing because there's people who are
saying the ratings are up and that means
Trump is doing well another saying the
ratings are down and Trump isn't doing
well but at the same time it wouldn't be
crazy to think that any president's
first address to a joint session of the
House and Senate would attract more
attention than subsequent ones I think
it's irrelevant a lot of people might be
paying attention because the president
is doing really well or really poorly
and a lot of people might choose not to
pay attention because they think the
president is either doing really well or
really poorly I don't care at all about
the ratings of the State of the Union
well Trump's first address to Congress
was right after he got inaugurated yeah
I think people were still in shock that
he was president and really run tune in
to see yet what it was gonna be like
when he's up in front of these
congressmen hydrators curiosity factor
yeah
total curiosity factor the first time
and even without Trump
the first time a president does this
there just might be more interest so I
would not focus much on the ratings
whatever it is that they are which by
the way people can't seem to agree on
Republicans saying best ratings in a
long time variety for example saying
actually the ratings were down from last
year so will we ever know the truth
will we ever care I said this is not a
hugely relevant issue also from the
david pakman show subreddit why did the
drunken peasants end before we got this
and the idea is that I look like actor
Kirk Cameron and that sargon of akkad a
classical liberal right I don't even
know what the call of youtuber looks
like one of the guys from the
home-improvement show I forget I forget
which guy but the cool guy with the
beard the co-host of the show with Tim
Allen anyway that's an old show I don't
know if anybody watches it but yeah so
there was going to be a debate between
Sargon of Akkad and I and the people on
the drunken peasants had reached out
about it and I had responded saying how
long is it going to be and what will be
the issues just kind of asking basic
questions never got a response and then
the drunken peasants ended as a program
yeah we initially thought that TJ and
the gang just lost interest the whole
idea of having you debates are gone
sure true I think well I think now we
realized that there was just so much
tour boil in the show yeah but they were
focused on other things
I guess so and you know the a lot of
people wrote in when it was on the table
and they said David don't waste your
time debating sargon of akkad we just
don't care it's not you know is it just
just don't do it it doesn't make any
difference add him on before we've had
he's never been on the program oh no no
I've done stuff YouTube only sno-cone
but the broadcast audience just doesn't
know who he is I don't think so I don't
know that it'd be hugely relevant anyway
yes there is absolutely no plan
currently for me to debate Karl Benjamin
and lastly from the David Pakman show
subreddit I seriously think hatred males
are written by trolls not by commited
conservatives Republicans or Trump
supporters we have a system for vetting
Patriot mail and I'm I'm not even
suggesting that it's foolproof but we
have many hate reott mails that we sort
of put in the category of deliberately
trolling not actual just hate mail and
we don't put those
to the best of our knowledge is it
possible that in the years of hatred
mail we've been tricked and put on a
message that was sent specifically to
try to get on hatred mail of course it's
impossible but we have a pretty good
system that's the reality we get tricked
every once in a while I think that's ok
yeah I mean it's still the segment is
still funny funny you know no matter
what no one really knows who exam and
arguably we don't know either at least
that's what this person is saying but I
think we have a pretty good sense of it
join the discussion on our subreddit at
david pakman.com slash re d di t